first key and we talked about the
financial education is people are waking
up to just hey i should have an
inflation hedge asset in my portfolio
right
absolutely there's a bucket there i got
to have it the way that i talk about it
is
each individual person so age income
level
goals all the optimizations are really
hard to kind of give you know one size
fits all advice right obviously
what i do know is the zero exposure to
bitcoin's the wrong answer
so i don't know if it's one percent five
percent ten percent right
each person's different but getting off
zero percent is really really important
because what it does is gold and bitcoin
while they both serve as inflation hedge
assets bitcoin has a
very very different return profile
meaning that it's much more asymmetric
so right now if you look earlier this
year right remember the volatility works
both directions so when
equities drew down 30 in march gold was
down 12 to 15 percent
bitcoin drew down on one day 50 percent
i mean you know it's just a nasty rip
your face off right yeah dude
now when we go the other direction and
asset prices increase
bitcoin's the best performing asset so
bitcoin's up like 45
year-to-date right gold's up about i
think it's 15 to 20 percent
equities are you know flat to kind of
single digit positive
in some of the indexes and so what you
start to realize
is if asset prices are going to go up
and the fed's going to continue to just
inject trillions of dollars of liquidity
and kind of all this macro stuff happens
you just want to have exposure to the
most asymmetric asset right so i don't
think bitcoin will ever go to zero
so your downside may be you know again
20 30 40 50
whatever it is but your upside is
hundreds of percent if not thousands of
percent
that brings me to here's the most
important thing you've got to know about
bitcoin the having
so if no one's explained this yet
there's something called the bitcoin
having
right and i'm going to tell you why this
is important i publicly in
december of 2018 came out and i issued a
million dollars my partners and i issued
a million dollar challenge
to any manager on wall street they could
pick any asset
any individual stock any asset for a
decade bitcoin will outperform it
million bucks goes to charity knock
yourself out not one person took it
here's why because the bitcoin having
is a programmatic decrease in the
incoming supply
so imagine if in 2008 when gold went
down 30
the government steps in they printed a
bunch of money everyone ran to gold
went up 200 percent hits an all-time
high in 2011. imagine when everyone ran
to gold
if 50 of the incoming supply of gold
got taken out of the market so 50 of the
miners just shut down
of course the price would explode right
that's what happened with bitcoin so
in march liquidity crisis occurs
government steps in starts printing
money
everyone runs for inflation hedge assets
bitcoin being one of a bunch
on in early may there was a drop from
each day 1800 bitcoin being created to
now each day there's only 900 being
created
and that happens every four years so
that'll go on for four years 900 a day
get created
and then it'll get dropped to 450 after
that four year period
so programmatically what you see is
you're actually making the asset more
and more scarce over time
but it just so happens that this last
one occurred
at the exact macro environment where
everyone's rushing for inflation hedge
assets and so i actually think bitcoin's
price is going to
top 100 000 by the end of next year see
i i have to say i'm not going to
disagree that and the reason why i've
been focused on it lady gave me the
education on it
stan drucker miller is a friend of mine
and he's a great investor
though he is a steeler fan which then
causes complications
although i have juju uh simon schuster
there i always call him simon
but here's the problem he said yesterday
that in three to five years we're all
going to have to pay for what the
government
and uh my friend joe kernan asked me
that and i said i have been
so possessed by that because i know
that we're going to get hurt so when i
go to my inflation handbook what it says
is buy gold buy masterpieces and by
mansions those are the three things that
that's it
my age okay those are the three things
you had to do now my wife's in real
estate so we've gone with the real
estate as our hedge all right
what we didn't have in that menu was
krypto and i think that you have to have
i'm going to say still say gold or crypt
because i have so much gold but
you have to have one or the other and i
like what you're saying about crypto i'm
not even
remember i'm not in gold for the
appreciation i'm in the go i'm in gold
for the
alternative but i don't know how my kids
are going to pay down what happened
uh i i think we had to do it to avoid
the depression so i'm glad we did it
but i see the dollar going down and most
importantly i know that no one wants to
raise taxes in this country
and even if we did raise taxes we still
can't afford it
we're not cutting social security we're
not cutting medicare
we're on a collision course where which
makes me feel great about the gold i own
but i do feel that it's perfectly
logical to add crypto
to the menu um and now after speaking to
you i think
that my kids when they get my
inheritance
won't feel comfortable with gold and
will feel comfortable with crypto
and i don't want them i want it i try to
put everything i own on one piece of
paper
they want to understand the deposit
boxes to say toronto dominion okay
but they would understand crypto and i
have to start recognizing
that maybe i am using um
maybe i am using a typewriter well
here's what i'll tell you is if you take
10 of your gold position right so just
whatever you have
allocated for your uh inflation hedge
bucket
if you take ten percent of that bucket
so let's save ten percent in gold you
just take one percent of your portfolio
right ten percent
okay take one percent you put it in
bitcoin
that one percent of bitcoin will
outperform the nine percent of gold over
the next 18 months
hands down not even close and you want
me to actually do the bit i
let my kids set up the bitcoin for me
yeah i'll do it
i'll help you do it whoever will help
you do it it's super simple and what you
end up doing is you would end up
owning one percent bitcoin right in your
portfolio if it goes to zero you lost
one percent not the end of the day right
not happy but not into that no but
that's okay
i i have stuff in it i have an
international uh fun that's done
terribly until now and i just said look
i i can't have
all my eggs in the u.s basket i want to
have
like i said i got the i i lost the
masterpieces to my
ex-wife god love her some beautiful
paintings hey man they're torso track
they're not gonna
um and but then i have the um i i have
the gold
uh i have the the so-called mansion the
real estate equation okay
and what i do is i need and i'm not a
you know a paid spokesman for why i need
gold
or why need crypto but i just need
something that my kids will understand
as i head to inflation
and they will never understand gold and
the reason why they'll never understand
gold
is they think gold's dangerous it's
dangerous because it can be stolen
it's dangerous because they don't want
to take it out of the bank uh it's
dangerous because
they may forget where it is okay i mean
you know let's say i freedom people
talking about like my crypto
gets hacked or whatever you know what's
really bad is when your kids can't find
your goal and that is by the way not
unusual
so this is why i am fixated on it
needing to own crypto
uh because i fear massive amount of
inflation and i don't have
you know gold do okay and the houses
will do okay those are going to keep me
running in place as opposed to pulling
off a cliff the idea of actually making
money
well holy cow i take a shot at that with
one percent
think think about this so one thing is
important right is when you talk to
your kids about it you got to make sure
it's bitcoin not just crypto in general
right because bitcoin specifically has
the inflation hedge
uh things that we're talking about here
uh the other ones you know advantages
disadvantages but bitcoin specifically
is this kind of inflation hedge
type asset the thing that i would say
is uh that people forget when they hear
this though becomes very attractive
60 40 global portfolio over the last
five years or so about 7.2 percent
return right annually right if you had
taken one percent of your assets and put
it in bitcoin
even with all the crazy ups and downs
everything you would have taken that 7.2
and gone to 9.2 so it added 200 basis
points of performance annually
right if that one percent had gone to
zero you'd gone from seven point two to
seven percent
so 20 basis point downside 200 basis
point upside
so it's literally ten to one in terms of
risk reward right right the key is the
standard deviation of risk stays about
the same
and the sharp sharp ratio goes up over
20 percent
really because it's a non-correlated
asset over long periods of time
now i'm correlated asset you're so right
now let me ask you a very obvious
question for you but not for me
okay um will
my kids understand where it's kept
i mean is it an app so the way to think
about this is
uh wherever you buy stocks the way that
your kids are going to
get access to that is either through a
will or
you're gonna have to tell them username
password all that kind of stuff right
same thing here so if you don't
self-custody it meaning that you
actually take physical possession you
know sovereign possession
what you would have to do is let's say
that you use uh gemiini the winklevoss
thing right you can go on set up an
account got a username and a password
you buy uh bitcoin you can hold it in
they have a custody
solution right and then you just got to
make sure that your kids or
whoever oversees the will or whatever
knows how to get access to that account
right the exact exact same thing i'm
thinking about this is i have trust
my kids and they're they're laddered you
know when they turned 30 when they
turned their boat into
a 29-26 and i have stock for that
index funds because not only individual
stocks and i am thinking
that when they turn 35 and turn 40 i
would look i hope i'm there but you
never know right
uh i would love to have right now
some bitcoin in there but i'm worried
what they'll do is they'll read the will
say like where's the bitcoin what does
that do what did he do he made it
like high and dry i don't have the code
i know the code i just lost it someone
hacked it
i want them to feel comfortable when
they turned 35 and 40 that i didn't buy
them something that doesn't exist
yep the exact same thing i mean look as
long as you've got
uh in an account where you want to pass
it on you just got to have
them have the information on how to get
in the account now when square tells me
that they'll handle trades can you keep
it at
square or you really want to use like
the gemini uh you can keep it on
any of these exchanges one of the things
that you're just doing right just like
any other
um kind of financial institution is
you're just offloading some of the risk
to that financial institution so you've
got to underwrite their security their
solvency all that kind of stuff the the
key piece is
the bitcoin ethos right the hardcore
bitcoiner
is all about self-sovereignty so just
like you say hey go get the gold and put
it in
you know your backyard or put it in a
safety deposit box whatever
bitcoiners have the same ethos one of
the challenges for people who are
older or not as technical is that
there's a somewhat technical process
to take physical control of a digital
asset right
and so what i always tell people is like
get started by
getting off zero percent exposure so get
to one percent right hold it in
uh one of these kind of you know
well-known uh
large custody providers to start then
mentioning that gemini i know you don't
take any money
gemini is the one that that darian the
winklevoss twins that that's their
exchange right so i don't want to make
fun of they're actually great guys they
belong to a club that i belong to and
they're incredibly kind and upset and i
see them
i don't want to be making fun of it but
if you tell them if you tell them that
we talked and you're going to buy
bitcoin they'll be your best friend
hey you know they like my wife you know
she's the head of the entertainment
committee
at the club who we belong to and uh
i need to do this for my kids i need to
do it because
they are much more at risk than i am
because of what happened
let's say before this okay before
february before the pandemic
well i would have said you know why the
stocks are doing well
i feel like they're a good hedge against
inflation there's no inflation
but then everything broke down and now i
know i'm being reckless yeah i was being
prudent with cash okay that's what i
thought
because you have stock you have cash
that's great for your kids remember the
26 after what happened during this
period
it's not right i know now i went from
being prudent
to being reckless so do i have to go buy
them paintings again very hard and
subjective okay
real estate again taking care of i've
taken care of that asset
but i think that they will be by went by
the time they're 35 and 40
much more comfortable owning not the
gold that they have
but the bitcoin that they have because
they're
digital and i am analog i love that it's
you know and look i have no regrets
that's who i am and i've loved gold and
there's a lot of people who hated gold
the whole time i've loved it
and i've loved it before exactly what
you've been talking scarcity value i
like the touch of it
but the touch of it is no longer as
valuable as the scarce